It took a week to get there. Sailing 200 miles a day. Captain Moore had never heard of anything like it, never seen anything like it. It was as far from land as you can get, in the middle of the Pacific Ocean, and there it was. Trash.
花了整整一个星期才到达那里。每天航行200英里。摩尔船长从未听说过这样的事情，也从未见过这样的景象。那是离陆地最远的地方，在太平洋的正中央，而它就在那里。垃圾。
The least visited part of the ocean is the most visited by our trash. Soap bottles are quite commonly seen out there. We've picked up Nike basketballs, truck tires from the Pacific Northwest with the steel rims still on them, and we discovered a spill that went for ten miles of plastic shopping bags. Out here again, as far away from land as you can get anywhere on earth, out in the middle of the ocean, we found El Pollo Loco chalupa bags, Taco Bell bags, Baby Superstore bags. For 10 miles until it got dark we tracked these bags.
海洋中人迹最少的部分，却是我们垃圾造访最频繁的地方。肥皂瓶在那儿随处可见。我们捡到了耐克篮球、带着钢圈的太平洋西北地区的卡车轮胎，还发现了一片绵延十英里的塑料购物袋。再次来到这里，在地球上任何远离陆地的地方，在海洋中央，我们发现了El Pollo Loco快餐店的墨西哥玉米饼袋、塔可钟的袋子、婴儿用品商店的袋子。直到天黑前，我们追踪了这些袋子整整10英里。
Some of the trash falls off of freighters and other ships. Most of it comes from land, carried by ocean currents, to an area the size of Texas where it collects in the middle of nothingness. There are five spots like this on the Earth's oceans. Captain Moore has seen a lot of trash heading towards one of these spots, a line stretching as far as the eye can see. Several yards wide.
有些垃圾是从货轮和其他船只上掉下来的。大部分垃圾来自陆地，被洋流带到了一个德克萨斯州大小的区域，汇集在这一片虚无之中。在地球的海洋里，有五个这样的点。摩尔船长看到很多垃圾正向其中一个点汇集，那是一条延伸到视线尽头的长龙。有几码宽。
It was quite a shocker because we couldn't find the end of it. We sent a dinghy out going one way, and we took the boat going the other way, and we got so far apart we were scared of losing each other. And we still hadn't come to the end of it. And there's no agency, no funding agency, no government agency, that takes responsibility for that part of the ocean. And really there's no government that controls it.
这太令人震惊了，因为我们找不到它的尽头。我们派出一艘小艇向一个方向行驶，我们则驾驶母船向另一个方向，我们分得太开了，以至于害怕失去彼此。但我们仍然没有到达它的尽头。没有任何机构、没有资助机构、没有政府机构对海洋的那一部分负责。实际上，也没有任何政府能控制它。
What that means is that Charles Moore, whose boat is a scientific research vessel, cannot find anybody to fund studies of what all this trash is doing to the creatures and the ecology of the ocean. Much less do something about all this garbage. You don't hear very often about places where nobody is in charge at all, where there's just nobody to appeal to.
这意味着查尔斯·摩尔（他的船是一艘科学研究船）找不到任何人来资助研究这些垃圾对海洋生物和生态造成了什么影响。更不用说处理这些垃圾了。你很少听说过根本没有人管辖的地方，在那里根本找不到可以求助的对象。
Well today on our program, we bring you stories of places like that. Stories from the middle of nowhere. You're listening to This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today, two stories from the middle of emptiness. Act one is about a tiny island where a lot of shady business has been going on precisely because there is no one around to see it. Act two is about a middle of nowhere experience much closer to home. An experience probably every single one of us has had at one point or another. We call that act, On Hold, No One Can Hear You Scream. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将带给你关于这类地方的故事。来自“虚无之地”的故事。你正在收听的是芝加哥WBEZ电台制作的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，有两个来自虚无中心的故事。第一幕关于一个小岛，那里之所以发生许多阴暗的勾当，正是因为周围没有人看到。第二幕是关于一个离家更近的“虚无之地”经历。这可能是我们每个人在某个时刻都曾有过的经历。我们把那一幕称为：保持通话，没人能听见你的尖叫。请继续收听。
Act one, No Island is an Island. The middle of nowhere figures heavily in conspiracy theories. You know, in a conspiracy theory you've got to have a remote place where the bad guys are going to congregate and plot. Bohemian Grove. Bretton Woods. The hollowed out volcano in Dr. No. Add to that list one more geographical spot in the middle of nothingness. According to Jack Hitt there is a lot going on there.
第一幕：没有岛屿是一座孤岛。虚无之地在阴谋论中占有重要地位。你知道，在阴谋论中，你必须有一个偏远的地方，让坏人们聚集并策划阴谋。波希米亚森林俱乐部。布雷顿森林。邦德电影《诺博士》里那座空心的火山。把那个名单再加上一个虚无之中的地理位置。据杰克·希特说，那里发生了很多事情。
The middle of nowhere, it turns out, is at the center of everything. I don't mean that the way a zen master or a motivational speaker might. I mean it literally. The middle of nowhere is at the center of everything. Specifically, the middle of nowhere is an island, isolated even by Pacific Ocean standards, 1,200 miles from the nearest smudge of land. A third the size of Manhattan, way east of New Guinea. On a map, a tiny dot in a massive hole in the middle of the sea.
事实证明，虚无之地正是万物的中心。我不是以禅师或励志演说家那种方式说的。我是字面意思。虚无之地就是万物的中心。具体来说，虚无之地是一个岛屿，即使以太平洋的标准来看它也是与世隔绝的，距离最近的陆地碎片也有1200英里远。它只有曼哈顿三分之一大小，位于新几内亚以东很远的地方。在地图上，它只是大海中央一个巨大的空洞里的一个小点。
This place is called Nauru. Heard of it? Don't worry. Almost no one has. Nauru is the place you've never heard of until you've heard of it, and then can't stop hearing of it. Part of the pleasure of knowing about Nauru is watching it pop up, Zelig-like, at the strangest world events. A covert spy operation involving a fake embassy in China. The world premiere of a London musical. The dark back room scheming of global terrorism. A dramatic rescue on the high seas. And an incident of international bankruptcy, as Jonathan Winer discovered.
这个地方叫瑙鲁。听说过吗？别担心。几乎没人听说过。瑙鲁是一个在你听说它之前闻所未闻，一旦听说就无法停止听到它的地方。了解瑙鲁的部分乐趣在于看它像《西力传》里的主角一样，出现在最奇怪的世界大事中。涉及中国假大使馆的秘密间谍行动。伦敦音乐剧的世界首演。全球恐怖主义的阴暗幕后策划。公海上的戏剧性救援。还有一场国际破产案，正如乔纳森·怀纳所发现的那样。
He remembers when he first heard of Nauru. He was Deputy Assistant Secretary of State at the time. What he was doing was trying to solve one of the great mysteries of the late 90s. How billions of dollars vanished from the former Soviet Union. Where he was at the time was Moscow, meeting with the vice president of Russia's central bank.
他记得第一次听说瑙鲁的时候。当时他是美国国务院副助理国务卿。他当时正在试图解决90年代末的一大谜团。前苏联消失的数十亿美元去了哪里。他当时身处莫斯科，正在会见俄罗斯央行的副行长。
I was sitting in his office, in the nice Scandinavian designed furniture offices of the central bank in Russia. Meeting with him to talk about the problem that the Russian central bank didn't have a clue what was happening to Russia's money. And he said, actually, we do have a clue. We know what's happening to the money. I said, what's happening to it? He said, Nauru. And I said, who's Nauru?
我坐在他的办公室里，在俄罗斯中央银行那些设计精美的斯堪的纳维亚风格办公室内。和他会面，讨论俄罗斯央行根本不知道俄罗斯的钱去了哪里这个问题。他说，其实，我们有一点线索。我们知道钱去了哪里。我说，去哪了？他说，瑙鲁。我说，瑙鲁是谁？
When I got back home, I got briefed by the CIA, I got briefed by the Treasury Department. Everyone thought it was very interesting that that's what had happened to Russia's money. We'd all been wondering what had happened to it. Now we had an explanation. It's really hard to assess quite how much of the Russian economy that was. The governor of the Central Bank estimated $70 billion over a relatively brief period of time.
当我回到家后，我接受了中央情报局和财政部的简报。每个人都觉得这就是俄罗斯的钱的去向，这非常有趣。我们都在好奇钱去了哪里。现在我们有了答案。真的很难评估那到底占了俄罗斯经济的多少。中央银行行长估计在相对较短的时间内流失了700亿美元。
How does a Pacific island liquidate a superpower? Well, for a while in the 90s, Nauru advertised on the internet permitting anyone to start a bank there for as little as $20,000. Make up a name, like the Panacea Bank. Actually, that one's taken. Quite notorious with the regulators.
一个太平洋岛国是如何清算一个超级大国的？嗯，90年代有一段时间，瑙鲁在互联网上做广告，允许任何人以低至2万美元的价格在那里开设银行。编个名字，比如“万灵药银行”。其实那个名字已经被用了。在监管机构眼中非常臭名昭著。
Anyway, here was the advantage. Most banks are required to keep an audit trail of money coming in and going out, like a standard statement for a checking account. Nauru didn't burden its banks with such fussiness. Nor did Nauru require that they ever tell anyone just who ran the bank. So when investigators went to track illicit money flows and got to the Panacea Bank, there would be no record of where the money came from. The trail would vanish. And Nauru would be under no obligation to say who ran it or where they lived.
总之，这里的优势是这样的。大多数银行都被要求保存资金进出的审计跟踪，就像支票账户的标准对账单一样。瑙鲁并没有用这种繁琐的要求来加重其银行的负担。瑙鲁也不要求他们告诉任何人到底是谁在经营银行。因此，当调查人员去追踪非法资金流向并找到“万灵药银行”时，根本没有任何资金来源的记录。线索会消失。而且瑙鲁没有任何义务说明是谁在经营或他们住在哪里。
Banks that would hide your tracks for you have always been around, but it was more of a gentleman's sport practiced with old world grandeur in Switzerland. Nauru led the way in democratizing offshore banking, taking it to the internet, lowering the cost to make it easier on middle income international criminal syndicates.
能为你隐藏踪迹的银行一直存在，但那更像是绅士运动，在瑞士以旧世界的排场进行。瑙鲁引领了离岸银行业的民主化，将其带入互联网，降低了门槛，使中等收入的国际犯罪集团操作起来更容易。
Collectively they've had a huge impact. When rain forest disappears, you wind up with extinctions. And when they launder money for people who are stealing a rain forest, you're facilitating a species extinction. Dictators make billions and hide it and then rape other countries again. So this kind of activity at a macro level has a huge impact all over the world. Welcome to the free market. No laws, no regulations. There you've got Nauru. The only thing that's forbidden there is disclosure.
总的来说，它们产生了巨大的影响。当雨林消失时，你会面临物种灭绝。当他们为盗窃雨林的人洗钱时，你就是在助长物种灭绝。独裁者赚取数十亿美元并将钱藏起来，然后再次蹂躏其他国家。所以这种宏观层面的活动在全世界都有巨大的影响。欢迎来到自由市场。没有法律，没有监管。这就是瑙鲁。那里唯一被禁止的就是披露。
Have you ever been there?
你去过那里吗？
No.
没有。
So when you say the word Nauru now, what image do you see in your mind?
那么现在当你提到“瑙鲁”这个词时，你脑海中浮现的是什么画面？
I see one of those Warner Bros. cartoon images of a desert island, with a single big palm tree on it. And I see a shack with a bunch computers on it, where somebody goes in and turns the power on in the shack. The lights go on, the computers start buzzing. There are little noises inside. There's a little fly paper on the wall as well as a fire alarm and a burglar alarm. And nobody is allowed to go inside. That's my image.
我看到的是华纳兄弟动画片里那种荒岛的形象，上面只有一棵大棕榈树。我看到一个装满电脑的棚屋，有人走进去把棚屋的电源打开。灯亮了，电脑开始嗡嗡作响。里面有细小的噪音。墙上贴着粘蝇纸，还有一个火警报警器和一个防盗报警器。而且没有人被允许进入。这就是我的想象。
Now that's probably not fair. It's probably a much nicer place than that. But you know, I was a government bureaucrat, so I'm paid to have negative views of things.
这可能不公平。那可能是一个比这好得多的地方。但你知道，我曾经是一名政府官僚，所以我被付钱去对事情持否定态度。
I'm one of the few people on the planet who can tell you this, but he's pretty close. I've knocked on the door of that shack. The first time I ever heard of Nauru was when a magazine editor called up a few years ago and asked me go there. I stepped over to my kid's globe to find the place. It wasn't there.
我是地球上极少数能告诉你的人之一，但他猜得很接近。我敲过那个棚屋的门。我第一次听说瑙鲁是几年前一位杂志编辑打电话让我去那里。我走到我孩子的地球仪前寻找那个地方。它根本不存在。
So I traveled to Brisbane, Australia to catch the Nauru plane. I say the plane because Nauru Airways owns only one, a Boeing 737, all that connects this island to the world. I was told I was lucky to be aboard since the president often commandeers it to fly in party supplies, or sometimes creditors trying to collect on one of Nauru's many debts seize it right on the runway. On the flight out, half the plane was taken up with giant plastic containers customized to fit ceiling to floor in the passenger seats. See, almost everything, including fresh water, has to be imported.
所以我飞往澳大利亚的布里斯班去搭乘瑙鲁的飞机。之所以说“那架飞机”，是因为瑙鲁航空公司只有一架飞机，一架波音737，这是连接这个岛屿与世界的唯一方式。我被告知能登机很幸运，因为总统经常征用它去运送派对物资，或者有时试图收回瑙鲁多笔债务之一的债权人会直接在跑道上扣押它。在飞往那里的航班上，半个机舱被装满了定制的巨型塑料容器，从地板一直堆到天花板。你看，几乎所有东西，包括淡水，都必须进口。
I checked into the private hotel. There's only one. I caught the cab, there's only one of those too. And I went to the shack where, at that time, much of the world's money laundering occurred. It's a broken down building, basically two rooms. Crammed with air conditioners to keep the computers humming in Nauru's brutal heat. I knocked on the door and a woman with a broom appeared, who told me there was no one there and never would be. It was as close as I or anyone would ever get to the red hot center of it all. The cleaning lady of the new global economy. I've met her.
我入住了那家私人酒店。那里只有一家。我叫了出租车，那种车也只有一辆。我去了那个当时大部分世界洗钱活动发生的棚屋。那是一座破旧的建筑，基本上只有两个房间。为了在瑙鲁酷热的天气里让电脑保持运转，里面挤满了空调。我敲了门，一个拿着扫帚的女人出现了，她告诉我那里没有人，也永远不会有人。那是我或任何人能接近的核心地带。新全球经济的清洁女工。我见过她。
The next day though, I realized that Nauru was also at the center of a completely different story. I called the cab for an island tour. The driver this day, whose name sounded like Brian, took me on a slow tour around the outer edge of the island. Then he asked me if I wanted to see the interior, known as Topside. When I said I did, the mood in the cab noticeably darkened. But he turned off one of the few side roads, and we headed in. Right away the trees disappeared. I immediately saw that the palms and pandanas you see on the shore are kind of scrim. A curtain, hiding from sight one of the scariest things I've ever seen.
不过第二天，我意识到瑙鲁也是一个完全不同故事的中心。我叫了辆出租车进行环岛游。那天开车的司机，名字听起来像布莱恩，带我绕着岛屿外缘慢慢转了一圈。然后他问我想不想看看内部，也就是被称为“顶部”（Topside）的地方。当我说想时，车里的气氛明显变沉重了。但他转入了一条为数不多的支路，我们向里驶去。树木立刻消失了。我立刻看到你在岸边看到的棕榈树和露兜树就像一种伪装。一道帘子，隐藏着我见过最可怕的事物之一。
Almost all of Nauru is missing. Picked clean, right down to the coral skeletons supporting the island. It's a haunting landscape of dugout stone channels formed by limestone towers and coral outcroppings, all blindingly white under an intense equatorial sun. The winding channels among these coral spires are lined with an appallingly silky dirt, and old, filthy trash, too expensive to export from the island, blows around this blistering desert. Shreds of plastic bags snag on bits of coral, and feral dogs hunt in the canals.
瑙鲁几乎全不见了。被彻底掏空，一直到支撑岛屿的珊瑚骨架。这是一个令人心碎的景观，由石灰岩塔和珊瑚露头形成的采石通道，在强烈的赤道阳光下白得刺眼。这些珊瑚尖顶之间的蜿蜒通道里铺着令人作呕的丝滑泥土，还有旧的、肮脏的垃圾——因为从岛上出口太贵——在这一片灼热的荒漠中到处乱飞。塑料袋的碎片挂在珊瑚碎片上，野狗在运河里觅食。
Brian told me how when he was a boy, all this was dense tropical forest. We sat in a hissing silence for a while. There was no breeze, just fine talc, airborne and stagnant.
布莱恩告诉我，当他还是个男孩时，这里曾是茂密的原始热带雨林。我们坐在一片嘶嘶作响的寂静中沉默了很久。没有微风，只有细细的滑石粉，在空气中弥漫，停滞不动。
So what happened? To really understand, you have to go back a million years, to when Nauru was a young coral atoll. It served as a favorite bathroom break for exhausted sea birds. Even in pre-history, Nauru was the middle of nowhere. Eventually the guano was covered in topsoil, and then a tropical forest. Some 2,500 years ago, the first humans arrived. And the developing Nauruan people lived there for millennia without much outside interference. There were no mosquitoes, no disease. Temperate air year-round, so no need for clothes. They fished the shore, and hunted the noddy birds and terns. There was an abundance of fresh fruit and water. In short, it was the kind of paradise we all imagine where we hear the words Pacific island.
那么发生了什么？要真正理解这一点，你必须回到一百万年前，当瑙鲁还是一个年轻的珊瑚环礁时。它曾是疲惫的海鸟最喜欢的如厕休息点。即使在史前时代，瑙鲁也是虚无之地。最终，鸟粪被表土覆盖，然后变成了热带雨林。大约2500年前，第一批人类抵达。瑙鲁人在那里生活了数千年，没有受到太多外界干扰。没有蚊子，没有疾病。全年气候温和，所以不需要衣服。他们捕食岸边的鱼，猎捕黑玄燕鸥和燕鸥。这里有充足的鲜果和淡水。简而言之，这就是我们听到“太平洋岛屿”这个词时所想象的那种天堂。
And it turns out, if you take an eon's worth of bird guano, and bake it in an equatorial sun, and compost it beneath a tropical forest, you'll have something valuable in about a million years. Say, by about 1896.
结果证明，如果你收集一纪元的鸟粪，在赤道阳光下烘烤，在热带雨林下堆肥，大约一百万年后你就会得到非常有价值的东西。比如说，到了1896年左右。
In about 1896, a man named Henry Denson, who was working for something called the Pacific Islands Company, was on Nauru. And he picked up a rock that he thought looked like petrified wood.
大约在1896年，一个叫亨利·丹森的人，为一家叫“太平洋岛屿公司”的机构工作，他当时在瑙鲁。他捡起一块石头，觉得看起来像石化木。
This is Carl McDaniel, an ecologist with the Rensselaer Polytechnic. He says Denson worked for a company that was in the phosphate business in Sydney. He left Nauru and took his rock back with him, where he used it as a doorstop.
这是伦斯勒理工学院的生态学家卡尔·麦克丹尼尔。他说丹森为悉尼一家从事磷酸盐业务的公司工作。他离开瑙鲁时把那块石头带回去，把它当成了门挡。
And it ended up holding open the laboratory door to the phosphate testing facility for about three years. And then in 1900 a guy named Albert Ellis came on temporary assignment. And he was a chemist. And he came down to test the samples that were coming in from the islands, and he looked at that rock and he said, that looks like phosphate. And Henry Denson said to him, no, no. It's just petrified wood, I picked it up on Nauru. Well for about three months, Albert Ellis walked in and out of that laboratory, and finally curiosity just took him over. He was like, I've got to test it. He chipped off a piece and it was the richest phosphate ore ever assayed at that time.
它就这样支撑着磷酸盐测试实验室的门大约三年。然后到了1900年，一个叫阿尔伯特·埃利斯的人来做临时指派。他是一名化学家。他下来测试岛上送来的样本，他看着那块石头说，那看起来像磷酸盐。亨利·丹森对他说，不，不。那只是石化木，我在瑙鲁捡的。嗯，大约三个月里，阿尔伯特·埃利斯进出那个实验室，最后好奇心战胜了他。他想，我必须测试一下。他敲下了一块碎片，那是当时 assayed（化验）出的最丰富的磷酸盐矿石。
This discovery plunged Nauru into the Industrial Age in the most brutal way. It became a strip mine, with a succession of different owners. First Germany, then Japan during World War II, and then Australia until the late '60s when colonialism went out of fashion. Nauru became an independent nation in 1968 and took control of the mines. The money poured in. By the late '80s, Nauru was the richest country per capita in the world. And they luxuriated in it. Everyone bought a car, even though the drive around the entire perimeter of the nation can't last much more than 30 minutes. They built cinder block houses, the hotel went up. Everyone got satellite TV, Western food arrived. Nauru Airline started flying. And in the final sign of post-colonial arrival, they built a golf course in the middle of nowhere.
这一发现以最残酷的方式将瑙鲁推向了工业时代。它成了一个露天矿，换了一连串不同的所有者。先是德国，二战期间是日本，然后是澳大利亚，直到60年代末殖民主义不再流行。瑙鲁在1968年成为独立国家并接管了矿场。钱涌了进来。到80年代末，瑙鲁是世界上人均最富有的国家。他们沉溺其中。每个人都买了车，尽管绕国家一周的车程不会超过30分钟。他们盖了煤渣砖房，酒店拔地而起。每个人都有了卫星电视，西式食物运到了。瑙鲁航空公司开始运营。而在后殖民时代到来的最后标志中，他们在虚无之地建了一个高尔夫球场。
And just like for everyone else in the '90s, the bubble burst. Nauru's financial advisers in the west robbed them blind. One of them, Adrian Powles of London, looted $60 million. Another boondoggle was producing a play in London. Maybe you missed the musical based on the amorous adventures of da Vinci, called Leonardo, A Portrait of Love.
就像90年代的其他所有人一样，泡沫破裂了。瑙鲁在西方的财务顾问把他们洗劫一空。其中一个，伦敦的阿德里安·鲍尔斯，掠夺了6000万美元。另一个挥霍的案例是在伦敦制作一部戏剧。也许你错过了那部基于达芬奇风流韵事的音乐剧，叫《莱昂纳多：爱的肖像》。
[MUSIC - LEONARDO, A PORTRAIT OF LOVE]
[音乐 - 《莱昂纳多：爱的肖像》]
It closed a few weeks after it opened, losing tens of millions of dollars for its principal backer, Nauru. By the late '90s, the country was in ruins. With the money gone, it was easier to turn around and see what they'd done to their homeland.
它在首演几周后就关门了，为其主要支持者瑙鲁损失了数千万美元。到90年代末，这个国家已是一片废墟。钱没了，人们回头看看自己对家园做了什么，反而更容易看清了。
Probably 70% of the island is mined out ruins. You can't walk through it, it's of no use to you. So the people on this island are in big trouble. They can no longer really get from the island those life support functions one needs in order to live somewhere.
大概70%的岛屿被挖掘成了废墟。你无法穿越它，它对你毫无用处。所以岛上的人陷入了巨大的困境。他们已经无法再从岛上获得住在某处所需的生活支持功能。
When you're on Nauru, there's a palpable sense of shame at what they've done. Bring up the mining with anyone, a hotel clerk, a cab driver, a postal worker, and their face goes tense. It's hard to understand because the Nauruans have done something almost unparalleled. Imagine if France had paved Bordeaux, or if Japan had carted away Fujiyama by the truckload. The Nauruans literally sold off their homeland for a pot of wealth, which is now lost.
当你在瑙鲁时，有一种对他们所作所为显而易见的羞愧感。跟任何人提起采矿的事，酒店职员、出租车司机、邮递员，他们的脸都会变得紧绷。这很难理解，因为瑙鲁人做了一些几乎前所未有的事。想象一下，如果法国铺平了波尔多，或者日本把富士山一卡车一卡车地运走了。瑙鲁人真的把他们的家园出卖换取了财富，而现在那笔钱也没了。
There are probably rationalizations and explanations, and plenty of others to blame. And yet, it's an incomprehensible thing to see it and feel it. And once they've done it, they had to find something else to sell. Most recently, suspected terrorists have been arrested carrying Nauru passports, which it appears can be easily obtained for something around $15,000 to $30,000.
可能有很多合理化和解释，也有很多人可以指责。然而，看到它并感受它是一件不可理喻的事情。一旦他们这样做了，他们就必须找到其他东西来出售。最近，有被怀疑是恐怖分子的人带着瑙鲁护照被捕，看来只要花大约1.5万到3万美元就能轻易获得。
A few years ago, they began marketing their very isolation. And the world learned of it in the usual way. When Nauru's name popped up in the middle of a story that should have nothing to do with the place. Like this story, of a Norwegian cargo ship in a standoff with the Australian coast guard.
几年前，他们开始营销他们的那种“与世隔绝”。世界以通常的方式得知了这一点。当瑙鲁的名字出现在一个本不该与它有任何关系的故事中间时。就像这个故事，关于一艘挪威货船与澳大利亚海岸警卫队的对峙。
Australian commandos armed with automatic weapons headed out to stop the Norwegian ship from docking at an Australian port. On board, 434 Afghan, Sri Lankan, and Pakistani refugees, including 43 children and four pregnant women, all living in sweltering heat on deck.
配备自动武器的澳大利亚突击队出动，阻止这艘挪威船只停靠在澳大利亚港口。船上载有434名阿富汗、斯里兰卡和巴基斯坦难民，包括43名儿童和4名孕妇，他们都生活在甲板上闷热的环境中。
That's ABC News. The story is about a boatload of refugees, mostly Afghans fleeing the Taliban. Their wooden ship was sinking in the waters off Australia, and the Aussies flew helicopters out over them for three days, taking no action until they spotted a Norwegian cargo vessel nearby. The Australians then radioed the captain, told him of the SOS situation, and advised him to take the wreckage to Indonesia. The Norwegian captain hurried to the sinking boat and pulled over 400 refugees onto his cargo ship, ill equipped to handle such a crowd. Obviously, he had to take immediate action, heading for the closest port that could handle them. Australia. But Australia didn't want these people, so for days there was a standoff at sea until Australia came up with a solution.
那是美国广播公司新闻网的报道。这个故事是关于一船难民，大部分是逃离塔利班的阿富汗人。他们的木船在澳大利亚附近海域下沉，澳大利亚人出动直升机在他们上方盘旋了三天，直到他们发现附近有一艘挪威货船，才采取行动。澳大利亚人随后呼叫船长，告知他求救情况，并建议他把这些沉船遇难者带到印尼。挪威船长赶到沉船处，将400多名难民拉上了他那并没有配备处理这种人群设施的货船。显然，他必须立即采取行动，驶向最近能安置他们的港口：澳大利亚。但澳大利亚不想要这些人，所以海上对峙了几天，直到澳大利亚想出了一个方案。
Now the plan is to take them another 3,000 miles to Papua, New Guinea, where one group will be flown to New Zealand and a larger one to the desolate Pacific island of Nauru.
现在的计划是把他们再带走3000英里到巴布亚新几内亚，其中一部分人将被送往新西兰，大部分人被送往荒凉的太平洋岛屿瑙鲁。
What the Norwegian captain didn't know was that he had sailed right into the middle of an ugly national election. Australian Prime Minister John Howard was down in the polls and seemed destined to lose. Then he stood his ground regarding the refugees. He declared, "We will decide who comes into this country." After he ordered his Navy to board the Norwegian vessel and remove the refugees to Nauru, his ratings shot right up and he easily won reelection. In exchange for locating the refugees on this distant island, he agreed to pay the Nauruan government a first installment of $20 million, with more to come. Australian senator Andrew Bartlett was one of the few politicians to oppose Howard's deal. A deal the prime minister liked to call, the Pacific Solution.
挪威船长不知道的是，他刚好航行到了一场丑陋的国家选举的中心。澳大利亚总理约翰·霍华德当时民调落后，似乎注定要失败。然后他在难民问题上立场强硬。他宣称：“我们将决定谁能进入这个国家。”在他命令海军登上挪威船只并将难民转移到瑙鲁后，他的支持率飙升，并轻松赢得了连任。作为将难民安置在这个偏远岛屿的交换条件，他同意向瑙鲁政府支付2000万美元的首期款项，未来还有更多。澳大利亚参议员安德鲁·巴特利特是为数不多反对霍华德这笔交易的政治家之一。总理喜欢把这笔交易称为“太平洋方案”。
Well, it certainly strikes me as a bit sinister. It's a bit like the final solution. And also, it's like any sort of policy that basically means getting rid of people and sending them back somewhere else where they're not our problem anymore. Calling that a solution, again, I think is pretty sinister.
嗯，这确实让我觉得有点阴险。这有点像“最终方案”。而且，这就像任何基本上意味着摆脱人们并将他们送回别处，让他们不再是我们麻烦的政策。再次称这为“方案”，我认为非常阴险。
You won't be hearing from the refugees. Since they landed on the island in September 2001, Nauru has closed its borders. No tourists or journalists are allowed. The refugees cannot receive visitors. And Australia has picked up other refugees on the water and sent them into the camps, including Iraqis escaping Saddam Hussein.
你听不到难民的声音。自从他们2001年9月登陆该岛以来，瑙鲁就关闭了边界。游客或记者都不允许进入。难民不能接待访客。澳大利亚还在海上拦截了其他难民并将他们送进营地，包括逃离萨达姆·侯赛因的伊拉克人。
Today of the roughly 400 detainees, mostly men, about a hundred are children, half are from Iraq, half from Afghanistan. These people fleeing the Taliban, escaping Saddam Hussein, are technically our allies. Yet they live in conditions not much different than our sworn enemies housed at Guantanamo. They are not permitted to mingle with the Nauruans. They don't work, but sit all day in concentration camps.
今天，在大约400名被拘留者中，大部分是男性，约有100名是儿童，一半来自伊拉克，一半来自阿富汗。这些逃离塔利班、逃离萨达姆·侯赛因的人在技术上是我们的盟友。然而，他们生活在与关塔那摩关押我们宿敌的环境没什么不同的条件下。他们不被允许与瑙鲁人接触。他们不工作，整天坐在集中营里。
From the start, the authorities recognized that the detainees were becoming lethargic and morose. So they hired Maarten Dormaar, a Dutch psychiatrist, who came to Nauru. He was hampered by the fact that rural people from Afghanistan and Iraq don't have a rich tradition of talk therapy, or opening up to a grief counselor. So their anxiety manifested itself in physical ways.
从一开始，当局就意识到被拘留者变得迟钝和郁闷。因此，他们聘请了荷兰精神科医生马尔滕·多尔马尔，他来到了瑙鲁。他的工作受到了阻碍，因为来自阿富汗和伊拉克的农村人没有那种谈话治疗或向悲伤咨询师敞开心扉的丰富传统。所以他们的焦虑以生理方式表现出来。
There was a boy who only came to me because of his stuttering. He said, I can't speak anymore, properly. And the more emotionally loaded my questions were, then he started to stutter. As soon as he had to pronounce a word like brother or father, he couldn't go on talking. It was clearly an emotional reaction, a reaction to his being overloaded with, how do you call, [DUTCH WORD] how do you call that in English? Longing for, hey, he was a young boy. Longing to see his mother, longing to be comforted, longing to have an arm around his shoulders. And there he is, all alone, in a long house with people that he cannot trust and he cannot confide in. It's very understandable.
有个男孩来找我只是因为口吃。他说，我再也不能说话了，正常地说话。每当我的问题情感色彩越重，他就开始口吃。一旦他必须说出“兄弟”或“父亲”这样的词，他就无法继续下去。这显然是一种情感反应，一种对他被过载的反应，怎么说呢，[荷兰语词] 英语怎么说？对，他还是个小男孩，渴望见到母亲，渴望被安慰，渴望有人搂着他的肩膀。而他却孤身一人，住在一间长屋里，周围的人他不能信任，也无法倾诉。这非常可以理解。
Most of them didn't sleep. That is their main complaint. They didn't sleep till 4:00 or so. And then they said, did you sleep afterwards. No, I didn't sleep, I just rested a little. Pain in their back, in their head. I mean, they always want sleeping pills and pills for headache. Fear of dying. Feeling of fainting. And so the feeling that you can't breathe anymore. Self mutilation, with a knife over the chest and over the arms and so on, a lot of blood. This happened at least a dozen of times.
他们大多数人睡不着觉。那是他们的主要抱怨。他们直到4点左右才睡。然后他们问，之后睡了吗？不，我没睡，只是稍微休息了一下。背痛，头痛。我是说，他们总是想要安眠药和头痛药。害怕死亡。有晕厥的感觉。还有感觉喘不过气。自残，用刀划胸口和手臂等等，流了很多血。这至少发生了十二次。
Dormaar tried to convince the authorities that none of the detainees had any mental illness. Simply put, they are being driven crazy. The cure was simple. Freedom, work, friends, life. All things he was powerless to provide. So he became quietly enraged. Struggling to figure out what to do, Dormaar clandestinely began to shoot videos of some of these young men. Dormaar gave them to a friend to smuggle off the island, and he retrieved them once he got out.
多尔马尔试图说服当局，这些被拘留者没有任何精神疾病。简单地说，他们是被逼疯的。治疗方法很简单。自由、工作、朋友、生活。所有这些他无力提供的东西。所以他陷入了默默的愤怒。多尔马尔挣扎着想该怎么做，开始秘密拍摄这些年轻人的一些录像。多尔马尔把它们交给朋友带出岛外，他在离开后取回了它们。
I have seen the videotapes. The men all speak in the same flat affect of people who no longer have exterior lives, but dwell entirely inside their own heads. One Afghan recalls the official visit by Australia's immigration chief, Phillip Ruddock, the man who rules their lives. When Ruddock arrived, all the camps' children and women were in their best clothes. They carried flowers, hundreds stood in formation to greet him. Ruddock entered, walked across the entire room to confer with the Nauruan officials, and didn't once acknowledge the detainees. He wouldn't even look at us, said the Afghan.
我看过这些录像带。男人们说话时都带着一种平淡的语气，那是没有外部生活、完全生活在自己头脑里的人才有的语气。一名阿富汗人回忆起澳大利亚移民局局长菲利普·拉多克的正式访问，那个掌管他们命运的人。当拉多克到达时，所有营地的孩子和妇女都穿上了他们最好的衣服。他们带着鲜花，数百人排成方阵迎接他。拉多克进入，径直穿过整个房间与瑙鲁官员商谈，却一次也没有理会那些被拘留者。那名阿富汗人说，他甚至不看我们一眼。
On another tape, Dormaar has smuggled an Iraqi named Mohammed out to the beach for an interview. At one point, Dormaar quotes Ruddock, insisting the detainees all have options. Here's Mohammed's answer.
在另一盘录像带中，多尔马尔偷偷把一个叫穆罕默德的伊拉克人带到海滩接受采访。在某个时刻，多尔马尔引用了拉多克的话，坚称被拘留者都有选择。这是穆罕默德的回答。
I want to say that, where's the options?
我想说，选择在哪里？
I want to say, where's the options?
I cannot see any options, just the sky and the water.
我看不到任何选择，只有天空和水。
I cannot see any options, just the sky and water.
I feel that I am completely powerless.
我感到自己完全无能为力。
I feel that I'm completely powerless. As he speaks, we see Mohammed sitting politely on a large rock in the sand. As he talks about his options, he looks off as though he sees something. The camera instinctively follows his gaze, and then we see it too. The actual reason Mohammed is on Nauru. A thousand miles of ocean, extending to the horizon, utterly still and empty. A painted sea without so much as a painted bird. The middle of nowhere.
我感到自己完全无能为力。当他说话时，我们看到穆罕默德礼貌地坐在沙滩上的一块大石头上。当他谈论他的选择时，他看向远方，好像看到了什么。摄像机本能地顺着他的视线跟了过去，然后我们也看到了。穆罕默德身处瑙鲁的真正原因。一千英里的海洋延伸到地平线，完全静止且空旷。一幅甚至连画上的鸟儿都没有的沉闷海景。这就是虚无之地。
I've been wrestling with that question of why is it that people allow this to happen and support it happening.
我一直在纠结这个问题：为什么人们允许这种情况发生并支持它发生？
Australian senator Andrew Bartlett.
澳大利亚参议员安德鲁·巴特利特。
I guess the closest I can come to understanding why it is, they don'y have to deal with it face to face. They don't actually have to see the people, they don't have to see what conditions they're in. The big reason for putting people on Nauru, because it's obviously incredibly expensive and there's no legal reason there why they need to put them on Nauru as opposed to Australian territory, is that they're so far away, they're inaccessible. They're just seen as a faceless group of people, a long way away.
我想我能理解的原因最接近的是，他们不需要面对面处理这些。他们实际上不需要看到这些人，不需要看到他们处于什么状况。把人关在瑙鲁的一大原因——因为这显然极其昂贵，而且在瑙鲁并没有任何法律理由需要把他们放在那里而不是澳大利亚领土——是因为他们太远了，难以触及。他们只是被视为一群无名之辈，离得太远了。
The detainees are still marooned on Nauru. Nauru continues to collect millions of dollars from the Australian government to house them. In a sense, Nauru is a lot like some isolated Appalachian town. First they strip mine themselves into ruin, then they build a prison to boost the local economy. What's left, other than a complete federal bailout by the United States government? Exactly. It arrived this summer. The details were dug out and reported by an Australian journalist, Cameron Stewart, of the Weekend Australian.
被拘留者仍然被困在瑙鲁。瑙鲁继续从澳大利亚政府那里收取数百万美元来安置他们。从某种意义上说，瑙鲁很像一些与世隔绝的阿巴拉契亚小镇。首先他们通过露天采矿使自己陷入废墟，然后他们建造一座监狱来提振当地经济。除了美国政府的全面联邦救助，还能剩下什么？没错。那是今年夏天的事。细节由澳大利亚记者、《周末澳大利亚》报的卡梅伦·斯图尔特挖掘并报道出来。
The first inkling that we had that Nauru had discovered a way to find new revenue sources through the US came to us when we got a bunch of documents, basically landing on a desk in our newspaper. And we're quite used to the sort of colorful stories that Nauru seems to throw up. So we waded through these papers and we suddenly saw documents, which contained some extraordinary information. Even by Nauruan standards.
我们得到瑙鲁通过美国找到新收入来源的第一个线索，是在我们收到一堆文件时，这些文件基本上是落在我们报社桌上的。我们已经很习惯瑙鲁似乎抛出的那种五花八门的故事。所以我们研读了这些文件，突然看到一些含有非凡信息的文件。即使以瑙鲁的标准来看。
The paperwork, including emails, personal correspondence, and memos on state department stationery, detailed a quid pro quo between Washington and Nauru. Washington offered to return Nauru to paradise with fisheries, health clinics, schools, desalination plants, the works. In return, Nauru had to stop its banking and passport business, set up a listening post for US intelligence agencies, and sign Article 98, exempting the US from all war criminal proceedings in the international courts. Standard stuff requested by the Bush administration these days. Oh, and there was one other thing. Nauru had to go on a secret mission.
这些文书，包括电子邮件、私人通信和美国国务院抬头备忘录，详细说明了华盛顿和瑙鲁之间的等价交换。华盛顿提议通过渔业、诊所、学校、海水淡化厂等项目让瑙鲁重返天堂。作为交换，瑙鲁必须停止其银行业和护照业务，为美国情报机构建立一个监听站，并签署《第98条》，豁免美国在国际法院的所有战争罪指控。这是布什政府这些天要求的标准操作。哦，还有一件事。瑙鲁必须执行一项秘密任务。
The way it was described to the Nauruans was this. The US wanted to use Nauruan diplomatic facilities in China to help facilitate the safe defection to the west of senior North Korean military and scientific personnel. Nauru would set up an embassy in China, and it would also set up an embassy car. And the car would be used, with a Nauruan flag, to help move people around the country. And the embassy would be used as a possible safe house to hold a defector until they could be safely moved to the West. The operation, they describe as Operation Weasel.
对瑙鲁人的描述是这样的。美国希望利用瑙鲁在中国的外交设施，帮助促成朝鲜高级军事和科学人员安全叛逃到西方。瑙鲁将在中国设立大使馆，还会设立一辆大使馆汽车。这辆车将悬挂瑙鲁国旗，用于帮助人员在全国范围内移动。而大使馆将被用作可能的安全屋，以扣留叛逃者，直到他们能被安全转移到西方。他们将此行动描述为“黄鼠狼行动”。
That's what he said. Operation Weasel. And according to Stuart, it got pretty far along. America had even manufactured Nauruan flags for use in China. The Chinese for their part, were a little suspicious, and never accredited the Nauruan embassy since it was staffed entirely by Westerners and run by a New Zealand spy. The deal back in Washington had been brokered by three government insiders. A congressional staffer on the House Financial Services Committee, a former Reagan official, and an American who also briefly ran the Nauruan embassy in Washington. As with so much of our foreign policy these days, the negotiations with Nauru were blunt. This email, which Stewart uncovered, explains the deal with a lot of moral clarity.
他就是这么说的。黄鼠狼行动。据斯图尔特说，这已经进行得很深入了。美国甚至为在中国使用制造了瑙鲁国旗。中国方面则有些怀疑，从未批准瑙鲁大使馆的认证，因为它的人员完全由西方人组成，并由一名新西兰间谍运作。华盛顿的那笔交易是由三名政府内部人士撮合的。一名众议院金融服务委员会的国会助手，一名前里根政府官员，以及一名曾短暂在华盛顿经营瑙鲁大使馆的美国人。和我们这些天很多外交政策一样，与瑙鲁的谈判很生硬。斯图尔特发现的这封电子邮件，以极其道德清晰的方式解释了这笔交易。
The background of this is that he didn't believe the Nauruans were taking the whole thing seriously enough. In other words, they weren't jumping to attention quickly enough. And he emails, and he says, if anyone wants to play effing games I'll end it all right now by making three phone calls. And that [BLEEP] hole in the middle of the Pacific will be left high and dry by everyone concerned.
这背后的背景是，他不相信瑙鲁人足够认真对待这件事。换句话说，他们没有足够快地跳起来立正。他发了一封邮件，说：如果有人想玩这些操蛋的游戏，我现在就结束一切，只要打三个电话。太平洋中央那个[哔]洞里的地方将被所有相关方弃之不顾。
Nauru went for the deal, though. After two high level meetings, including a visit to Washington by the Nauruan president Bernard Dowiyogo, the arrangements were made. And not a minute too soon.
不过，瑙鲁还是接受了这笔交易。在两次高层会议后，包括瑙鲁总统伯纳德·多维约戈对华盛顿的访问，安排就绪了。而且没过一分钟就太迟了。
President Dowiyogo's health went downhill quite seriously. And within about 10 days, he was dead. He had died, and really, his last act was to sign this presidential order agreeing to the list of US requests. Basically, the US government got everything it wanted, and Colin Powell wrote a letter to the Nauruan government shortly afterwards saying that Bernard Dowiyogo was a hero for Nauru. He'd secured the future of the country and he was a bold man of vision, he opposed terrorism, et cetera, et cetera. And so Nauru felt that they had done everything that was requested of them.
多维约戈总统的健康状况严重下滑。大约10天内，他就去世了。他去世了，事实上，他最后的行为是签署这份总统令，同意了美国的要求清单。基本上，美国政府得到了它想要的一切，科林·鲍威尔不久后写信给瑙鲁政府，称伯纳德·多维约戈是瑙鲁的英雄。他确保了国家的未来，他是一个有远见的大胆男人，他反对恐怖主义，等等等等。所以瑙鲁觉得自己已经完成了被要求的一切。
But when the state department was asked publicly about aid to Nauru, they not only denied the deal, but insisted that the men who made the arrangements with Nauru had no official authority. Meanwhile, understand, the Nauruans had held up their side of the deal. They outlawed offshore banking, which had cut off a big part of their income. So Nauru took the United States to court in Australia. Papers have been filed. Nauru is talking. In late summer, the court made its first ruling.
但当国务院被公开问及对瑙鲁的援助时，他们不仅否认了这笔交易，还坚称那些与瑙鲁安排事宜的人没有官方授权。同时，要明白，瑙鲁人已经履行了交易中他们的那一半。他们取缔了离岸银行业，这切断了他们收入的一大来源。所以瑙鲁在澳大利亚起诉了美国。文件已经提交。瑙鲁正在发声。夏末，法院做出了第一次裁决。
Now the court, in its summary judgment, found in favor of Nauru. And the judge, Justice Bill Gillard, said that various persons were named by Nauru as persons representing the US. It is open on the evidence to infer that these men were acting on the high executive authority from the US government. In other words, the Victorian Supreme Court found that the US used back channel diplomacy to bring Nauru in from the cold on terrorism, and was therefore liable for promises made in that process.
现在法院在简易判决中裁定有利于瑙鲁。法官比尔·吉拉德认为，瑙鲁指定的不同个人代表美国。根据证据可以推断，这些人是在美国政府的高级行政授权下行事的。换句话说，维多利亚州最高法院发现，美国利用后台外交将瑙鲁从恐怖主义的寒冷中拉出来，因此要对该过程中作出的承诺承担责任。
No matter what happens, it's hard to see this as a win for Nauru. It's a desperate act, even for a country so intimate with desperation. You know you're really running out of options when you're dunning the CIA for money owed on failed covert ops.
无论发生什么，很难将此视为瑙鲁的胜利。这是一种绝望的行为，即使对于一个与绝望如此亲密的国家来说。你知道你真的快没招了，当你在向中央情报局索要欠款以补偿失败的秘密行动时。
After I returned from my trip to Nauru, I was invited to have breakfast with the man who was president then, as he was earlier this year. Bernard Doriyogo greeted me with courtly dignity in his Park Avenue hotel suite, and soon chefs brought us eggs and toast. I asked him what new economies he imagined for Nauru. He said that since all the phosphate would be gone in only a few years, he was considering new proposals.
我从瑙鲁之行回来后，受邀与当时担任总统的那个人共进早餐，就像他在今年早些时候一样。伯纳德·多维约戈在公园大道的酒店套房里以宫廷式的庄重迎接了我，不久厨师就为我们端来了鸡蛋和吐司。我问他为瑙鲁想象了什么新经济。他说，由于所有的磷酸盐在几年内就会消失，他正在考虑新的提案。
He said that he was looking into a new technology that would allow him to cut the limestone pinnacles from Nauru's interior into flat slabs. Then he would polish them and sell them as ancient coral coffee tables in America. I asked President Doriyogo what other ideas he had. He looked at me blankly, and then he took a bite of toast.
他说他正在研究一种新技术，允许他将瑙鲁内部的石灰岩尖顶切割成平板。然后他会把它们抛光，在美国作为古珊瑚咖啡桌出售。我问多维约戈总统他还有什么其他想法。他茫然地看着我，然后咬了一口吐司。
How often you get to watch a country die? For a modern nation state, however small, to furl its flag, push in its UN chair and turn off the lights, is unthinkable. But for Nauru, it's not only thinkable, but likely. The ocean's waters are rising. If predictions are true, in a half century the sickly ring of green habitation at the water's edge in Nauru will be engulfed. The Nauruans will have to decamp for some other place.
你多久能看到一个国家死去？对于一个现代民族国家，无论多小，收起旗帜，推开联合国的椅子并关掉灯，是不可想象的。但对于瑙鲁，这不仅是可想象的，而且是可能的。海平面正在上升。如果预测属实，半个世纪后，瑙鲁水边那圈病态的绿色栖息地将被淹没。瑙鲁人将不得不搬迁到别处。
Australia has in fact offered Nauru one of its islands, off the Great Barrier Reef. If and when they ever take up such a solution, that will leave only the bleached lunar landscape of Topside, peeping above the water's surface, available once again, for the next million years, only to the birds.
事实上，澳大利亚确实向瑙鲁提供了其大堡礁附近的一个岛屿。如果且当他们真的采取这样的方案时，那将只剩下顶部那片漂白的月球景观，重新露出水面，在接下来的几百万年里，只留给鸟儿了。
Jack Hitt is one of our contributing editors. He lives in New Haven. Since we first aired that story in 2003, the number of detainees on Nauru is now down to 89 people according to Human Rights Watch.
杰克·希特是我们的一位特约编辑。他住在纽黑文。自我们2003年首次播出那个故事以来，据人权观察组织称，瑙鲁的被拘留人数现在下降到89人。
Coming up, the second largest long distance company in the country exiles a person to limbo for nearly a year. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，全国第二大长途电话公司将一个人流放到了地狱边缘将近一年。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，一分钟后节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, tales from the middle of nowhere. Stories of people trapped in some distant spot where all rules are off. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act two, On Hold, No One Can Hear You Scream.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，并带给你关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目，来自虚无之地的故事。那些被困在遥远偏僻之处、所有规则都失效的人们的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕：保持通话，没人能听见你的尖叫。
Back in 2003, one of the people who works on our radio show, Julie Snyder, our senior producer, fell into a 10-month-- black hole-- would be the best thing to call it. For 10 months she fought with the phone company, getting put on hold for hours at a time, trapped on hold in the middle of wherever it is that you are when you're on hold. There was nobody who she could turn to to stop the madness. Nobody seemed able to help her. You've gone through this, right? We've all gone through this kind of thing. And for most of us, it's over in just a couple phone calls.
回到2003年，在我们广播节目工作的人员之一，朱莉·斯奈德，我们的资深制片人，掉进了一个10个月的——黑洞——是形容它的最好词汇。10个月里她与电话公司斗争，每次被置于等待状态数小时，困在电话等待的虚无之中。没有谁能求助来停止这场疯狂。似乎没有人能帮她。你经历过这个，对吧？我们都经历过这种事情。而对我们大多数人来说，这只需几个电话就解决了。
Julie's vigil began in March 2003. She got this phone bill with $439 in long distance calls. One 23 minute call with her mom cost $43. Under her MCI plan-- this is back when MCI existed-- under her MCI plan it should have cost her $0.12 a minute, just under $3.00. So she called, to try to get them to fix the problem.
朱莉的守夜始于2003年3月。她收到的电话账单上有439美元的长途电话费。一个与她妈妈的23分钟通话花了43美元。根据她的MCI计划——这是MCI还存在的时候——根据她的MCI计划，这应该只需要0.12美元一分钟，不到3美元。所以她打电话，试图让他们解决这个问题。
They told me that on December 31st, I had called and requested that they drop me from my $0.12 cents a minute plan.
他们告诉我，12月31日，我打过电话并要求他们取消我的0.12美元一分钟的套餐。
And had you called on December 31st?
那你12月31日打过电话吗？
Yeah, I do do a lot of my business on New Year's Eve. No, of course I didn't call. Are they even open on New Year's Eve Day? It is so ridiculous. But I also told them a lie, and I don't know what you want to do with this one. If this would be-- just so we wouldn't have to haggle over the whole did you call, we have it down that you called, and no I didn't call and stuff. I just told them that it would have been impossible for me to call because I was in the hospital then.
是啊，我确实在除夕那天处理了很多业务。不，我当然没打。他们除夕那天甚至开门吗？这太荒谬了。但我还对他们撒了个谎，我不知道你想怎么处理这个。如果是为了——这样我们就不用为了“你到底打没打”来争执，我们记录显示你打了，而我没有打之类的事。我只是告诉他们我不可能打电话，因为我当时在医院。
In the hospital with what?
在医院是因为什么？
Giving birth.
生孩子。
I just didn't want to haggle over it. And I knew for sure that I hadn't called and I hadn't authorized anything. So I just figured it would just make it easier. They weren't going to argue anyway. Because I get the impression that this is what people call about all the time. This happens to everybody. You get, all of a sudden, just switched without your knowledge. This is the most common way to get screwed over by your phone company.
我只是不想为此争执。而且我确定我没打过电话，也没授权过任何东西。所以我认为这样会更容易。反正他们也不会争论。因为我得到的印象是人们一直在打电话询问这件事。这发生在每个人身上。你突然就在不知情的情况下被切换了。这是被电话公司坑到的最常见方式。
Over the course of two months, the phone company piled on a total of $946 in mistaken charges onto her bill. And for a while it seemed like the kind of thing that could be easily resolved. Sure, it took few phone calls. Her local service was with Verizon and long distance service was with MCI so it took a bit of wrangling to get them both on the same page. But after two rounds of calling, customer reps from both companies told her, yes, it's solved, in a three way conference call. This was April. Julie felt good.
在两个月的时间里，电话公司把总计946美元的错误费用加到了她的账单上。有一段时间，这似乎是很容易解决的事情。当然，这花了几通电话。她的本地服务是Verizon，长途服务是MCI，所以把他们两个协调到一起需要一点周旋。但在两轮通话后，两家公司的客服代表在三方通话中告诉她，是的，解决了。这是4月。朱莉感觉很好。
Then in June, she got a notice from a collection agency asking for the money. And this is where she pretty much made the transition from normal customer with a problem to someone lost at the bottom of a well.
然后在6月，她收到了一家催收机构要求还钱的通知。这就是她基本从一个有问题的正常顾客，转变成一个被困在井底的人的过程。
So I called Verizon, and I say that I want to do a three way call again because clearly, they told me that this thing was being taken care of and it wasn't. They told me that I would have to call MCI because they can't initiate a three way call, that they simply don't have the technology to initiate a three way call.
所以我打电话给Verizon，我说我想再做一次三方通话，因为很明显，他们告诉我这件事正在被处理，但并没有。他们告诉我必须给MCI打电话，因为他们不能发起三方通话，他们根本没有发起三方通话的技术。
Wait, you mean literally they can't get two people on the phone at the same time and conference them?
等等，你是说他们真的不能让两个人在同一时间通话并把他们连线起来？
Apparently no, no. They can't do that. It's impossible for them.
显然不能，不能。他们做不到。对他们来说是不可能的。
They're a phone company, though. They sell that service. OK. So you call MCI.
但他们是电话公司啊。他们销售这项服务。好吧。那你给MCI打。
So then I called MCI and this is when I started losing it. Because this was the first time I cried.
所以我给MCI打，这时我开始崩溃了。因为这是我第一次哭。
Wow. The phone company made you cry.
哇。电话公司把你弄哭了。
This was the first time I cried.
这是我第一次哭。
How?
怎么会？
Well, because they said when I called-- then I finally called them and I got a hold of this customer service person, and then they told me that there wasn't any record of a credit issued at all for me for $946.36. And if you just ignore this, this is going off to a collection agency. And this is ruining your credit, right. So I just felt totally frustrated.
嗯，因为他们说当我打电话时——我最终打通了，联系到了这个客户服务人员，然后他们告诉我，根本没有任何关于为我开具946.36美元信用额度的记录。而且如果你只是忽略这个，这就会转交给催收机构。这会毁了你的信用，对吧。所以我感到完全沮丧。
And it's at that point that I just started freaking out, and just saying, you guys don't know what you're doing, and people have already told me I think two or three times that this has already been taken care of, and everything's fine, and stuff like that. And so finally then they transfer me to-- this is my first time being taken over to priority customer service-- and I get to priority customer service, and that's when I met Chuck Carter.
就在那一刻我开始抓狂，只是说，你们根本不知道自己在做什么，人们已经告诉我想想有两三次这件事已经解决了，一切都很好之类的。最后他们把我转接给——这是我第一次被转接到优先客户服务——我到了优先客户服务部，那时我遇到了查克·卡特。
And Who's Chuck Carter?
查克·卡特是谁？
Chuck Carter was like, the nicest man at MCI. OK, so I completely started crying when I got on the phone with him. And I was just like, you don't have any idea how frustrating this is, and I've been on the phone, and they're going to report me. And this guy, he works at MCI in priority customer service, but he also works at the suicide prevention hotline. Because he totally talked me through it in such a nice way. So calming and so social work-y. And like, was just, breathe, breathe.
查克·卡特就像MCI里最好心的人。好吧，所以当我打通他电话时我就彻底开始哭了。我只是说，你根本不知道这有多令人沮丧，我一直在打电话，他们还要举报我。而这个家伙，他在MCI优先客户服务工作，但他也在自杀预防热线工作。因为他确实以一种非常友好的方式引导我度过了难关。非常冷静，非常像社会工作者。而且，只是说，呼吸，呼吸。
No. He says, literally, breathe?
不。他真的说，呼吸？
Yeah, he did, breathe. And then he was just like, you know what Miss Snyder? I know that this is frustrating for you. I know that this makes you feel powerless. And I know that you feel out of control. And I know that it's hard to ask us, to put all your faith in us that we're going to take care of this. But I'm going to take care of this for you.
是的，他说了，呼吸。然后他只是说，你知道吗，斯奈德小姐？我知道这对你来说很沮丧。我知道这让你感到无能为力。我知道你感到失控。而且我知道很难要求我们，把所有的信任都寄托在我们身上，相信我们会处理这件事。但我会为你处理这件事。
It was so cheesy and so bizarre that it got me to stop crying, at least, because I was so confused by what was happening on the phone. But it also totally calmed me down. And he told me that now he was going to fill out the correct paperwork to get the credit issued. And that he was getting the manual form, and the digital form was the one that got lost before, but he was going to get the manual form.
这太俗气也太古怪了，至少让我停止了哭泣，因为我被电话里发生的事情搞糊涂了。但它也完全让我冷静下来了。他告诉我，现在他要填写正确的表格来开具信用额度。他要拿到纸质表格，之前的数字表格就是弄丢了，但他要拿到纸质表格。
And even when he had to go get the manual form, he was all just like, now Miss Snyder, I'm just going to get up from my desk, walk down the hall, and get the manual form. And then come back. This shouldn't take me longer than 30, 45 seconds. OK? So I'm not forgetting you, I'm just getting up to go to the manual form.
即使当他不得不去拿纸质表格时，他也是那样，斯奈德小姐，我现在要从办公桌上起身，沿着走廊走过去，去拿纸质表格。然后回来。这不会超过30到45秒。好吗？所以我不会忘记你，我只是起身去拿纸质表格。
And is there a part of you which feels, don't condescend to me, or are you just eating it up?
你内心有没有一种感觉，觉得“别对我居高临下”，还是你完全接受了？
I was kind of eating it up. I was really enjoying it. I felt like I was really being taken care of, and I felt like finally somebody understood my pain. And then he also gave me his name. And he said now, I want you to know my name, my name is Chuck Carter. I work in MCI priority customer service. If there's a problem you can come back to me. So I felt pretty good after this phone call.
我有点接受了。我真的很享受。我觉得我真的被照顾到了，我觉得终于有人理解我的痛苦了。然后他还告诉我他的名字。他说，现在，我想让你知道我的名字，我叫查克·卡特。我在MCI优先客户服务工作。如果有什么问题你可以回来找我。所以打完这个电话后我觉得挺好。
So then a week later, I call, and again they say that they don't know what I'm talking about. And that they can't find any request made for this credit, and they don't know what a manual form is. And then when I just begged, Chuck Carter, just Chuck Carter. Let me speak with Chuck Carter. They told me that they have no idea who Chuck Carter is, and they said that there are no individual extensions at the entire phone company. Nobody has an individual extension. At the phone company.
所以一周后，我打电话，他们又说他们不知道我在说什么。他们找不到任何关于这笔额度的申请，而且他们不知道什么是纸质表格。然后当我恳求时，查克·卡特，只是查克·卡特。让我和查克·卡特说话。他们告诉我他们根本不知道查克·卡特是谁，而且他们说整个电话公司没有任何个人分机。没有人有个人分机。在电话公司。
But how could they run a business where they can't call their own employees one by one? Like, how does Chuck Carter's wife reach him to say, pick up some milk on the way home?
但他们怎么能经营一家不能一个接一个联系自己员工的公司呢？比如，查克·卡特的妻子怎么联系他说，回家路上买点牛奶？
That's what I said, you know. And I was just like, I understand that you don't want to give me the number because you don't want me directly harassing your customer service representatives. And that's totally personal. I completely understand that, right. But why can't they call and get this person on the phone and try and figure out what's going on? And then they just told me it was impossible to do. And then I was just like, well, why would the guy have given me his name in the first place then if this wasn't possible to do? And they just said, I don't know, I don't know, maybe he was just trying to make you feel better.
我也是这么说的。我只是说，我理解你们不想给我号码，因为你们不想让我直接骚扰你们的客服代表。那是私人的。我完全理解，对吧。但为什么他们不能打电话把这个人叫到电话前，试着搞清楚发生了什么？然后他们只是告诉我那是不可能的。然后我就说，那如果这不可能做到，那家伙当初为什么要告诉我他的名字呢？他们只是说，我不知道，我不知道，也许他只是想让你感觉好点。
OK, so this goes on for weeks and weeks.
好吧，所以这持续了数周又数周。
This goes on for weeks, and finally I end up talking with a manager at MCI. And she tells me that I would have to file a complaint with the MCI complaints division. And so I said, OK, so can I get their phone number? And they don't have a phone number. They just have a fax number. You can only fax them, you can't call them. And that they're somewhere in Iowa. And I said, what if they can't figure out what's wrong? And she said, they'll definitely figure out what's wrong. And then I said, and how soon are they supposed to get back to you? And she said within two weeks.
这持续了数周，最后我终于和MCI的一位经理谈话。她告诉我必须向MCI投诉部门提交投诉。我说，好吧，那我可以拿到他们的电话号码吗？他们没有电话号码。他们只有一个传真号码。你只能传真给他们，不能给他们打电话。而且他们在爱荷华州的某个地方。我说，如果他们找不出问题所在怎么办？她说，他们一定会找出问题所在的。然后我说，他们打算多久给你回信？她说两周内。
Understand that, for like the last seven months, I've had people saying I'm going to call you next week, or I'll call you within two weeks, or I'll let you know. And I've never once gotten one phone call back from anybody at MCI, or a letter, or anything explaining what's going on. So I'm a little wary when they say that they'll get back with you within two weeks. And so I said, well, yeah, but what if they don't? And she was like, they do. They will. They always do. They always figure everything out and they always get back with you within two weeks.
你要知道，在过去的七个月里，一直有人说“我会下周给你打电话”，或者“两周内我会给你打电话”，或者“我会通知你”。我从来没有收到过任何一个MCI的人打来的电话，或信件，或者任何解释发生了什么的说明。所以我对他们说“两周内回信”时有一点警惕。所以我说，嗯，是啊，如果他们不回呢？她就说，他们会的。他们会。他们总是这样。他们总是能搞清楚一切，而且他们总会在两周内回信。
And so somewhere there's an office, they're saying, that there's an office where there's only a fax machine.
所以某处有个办公室，他们说，有一个只有传真机的办公室。
Like a silo, is how I like to picture it. Somewhere in the middle of Iowa there is this silo. I was just like, so, wait. So you're telling me that there's some building in the middle of Iowa that's filled with like, really prompt geniuses, who don't have any phones but just have one fax machine sitting in the middle of the room that gets incoming faxes. And they know everything and they'll take care of it, and she told me, yes. That's basically what it is.
我想象成一个筒仓。在爱荷华州的某个地方有这样一个筒仓。我只是说，等等。所以你告诉我有一座位于爱荷华州中间的建筑，里面挤满了比如，非常敏捷的天才，他们没有任何电话，只有一个放在房间中间的传真机，接收进来的传真。他们什么都知道，他们会处理好的，她告诉我，是的。基本上就是这样。
What is this employee's name? Let's say her name over the radio.
这个员工的名字叫什么？让我们在广播里说出她的名字。
That was Melanie Gladwell.
那是梅兰妮·格莱德威尔。
Do you hate what this has reduced you to?
你讨厌这让你变得如此不堪吗？
Yeah. I mean, I hate that it's made me sort of a screeching shrew on the phone. And I hate that it makes me angry and wishing revenge upon them. And you know, I'm the person that they sort of, just like, "Jesus" when they get off the phone. You know what I mean? And yeah, I hate all of that.
是啊。我是说，我讨厌它让我变成了一个在电话里尖叫的悍妇。我讨厌它让我愤怒并希望报复他们。你知道，我就是那种当他们挂断电话时，他们只会说“天哪”的那种人。你知道我的意思吗？是啊，我讨厌这一切。
I don't know what to do.
我不知道该怎么办。
Really?
真的？
No, I really don't know what to do.
不，我真的不知道该怎么办。
And so right now you're just waiting to hear from the geniuses in the silo?
所以现在你只是在等待筒仓里的天才回信？
Mhmm. I've been waiting for a week and a half, so I still technically have three days left that the geniuses could get back in touch.
嗯。我已经等了一周半了，所以严格来说天才们还有三天时间可以回复。
So, Julie, now, weeks have passed since that first conversation. The one that we just heard.
所以，朱莉，现在，距离那次第一次对话已经过去了数周。我们刚刚听到的那一次。
Yes, weeks.
是的，数周。
And so you've had time to hear from the geniuses in the silo. What's the word?
所以你有时间听到筒仓里的天才的回信了。什么消息？
Silence.
沉默。
So who are we calling today?
所以我们今天给谁打电话？
We're calling MCI today to find out if they know what's been going on.
我们今天给MCI打电话，看他们知不知道发生了什么。
All right. Well, let's go to it. Let me just say, before we place this call, Julie?
好的。嗯，我们开始吧。在我拨打这个电话之前，让我说一句，朱莉？
Yes?
是的？
You're in luck because you're about to see the power of the national media. The power that public radio has in this country. We're going to place this call, we're going to say who we are, we're going to indicate that they're on the record. And doors are going to open. Your problems will be solved.
你很幸运，因为你即将见证国家媒体的力量。公共广播在这个国家拥有的力量。我们将拨打这个电话，我们将说明我们是谁，我们将指出他们正在被录音。门将会打开。你的问题将会得到解决。
I truly believe that. I think that you're going to solve this problem.
我真的相信这一点。我认为你会解决这个问题。
Are you being serious or are you being sarcastic?
你是认真的还是在讽刺？
Actually, I don't even know what I believe. I think at first I thought that this was a really good idea. But I don't know. Honestly, over the last couple weeks in going through more and more of this, I actually don't even think you're going to be able to do anything.
其实我甚至不知道我相信什么。我想起初我觉得这是一个很好的主意。但我不知道。老实说，在过去几周经历得越来越多，我实际上甚至不认为你能做什么。
All right, well, let's find out.
好吧，让我们看看。
OK.
好的。
[DIAL TONE AND DIALING]
[拨号音和拨号声]
So we call. And some automated system picks up, asks us to punch in some answers to a few questions. Which takes over two minutes. And then, we get a customer service rep.
所以我们拨打了。然后一个自动化系统接起，要求我们输入对几个问题的回答。这花费了超过两分钟。然后，我们接通了一个客户服务代表。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] built by MCI, my name is Ferdie, what can I assist you with today?
[听不清] MCI为您服务，我叫弗迪，今天有什么可以为您效劳的吗？
I'm sorry, you said Ferdie?
抱歉，你说弗迪？
Yes sir.
是的，先生。
Hi, my name is Ira Glass, and I'm recording this for possible national radio broadcast, I work on a national radio show. One of my coworkers, her name is Julie Snyder, has an ongoing problem with her bill. Julie?
你好，我是艾拉·格拉斯，我正在为可能的全国广播播出录音，我在一家全国性广播节目工作。我的一个同事，她叫朱莉·斯奈德，她的账单一直有问题。朱莉？
Yeah, hi. I was calling-- should I give you the account number?
是的，你好。我打电话是——我应该提供账户号码吗？
Miss Julie, all right? And Miss Julie, may I also have your telephone number starting with area code, please?
朱莉小姐，好的。还有朱莉小姐，可以给我你的电话号码，从区号开始，好吗？
OK, the telephone number is 718-4848 but that's actually--
好的，电话号码是718-4848，但这实际上——
After she gives some basic information, Miss Julie asks if we can get bumped up to priority customer service. And then we sit on hold.
在她提供了一些基本信息后，朱莉小姐问我们是否可以转接到优先客户服务。然后我们就开始了等待。
Julie I talk about the music on hold. Julie has noticed that this song has no beginning and no ending. Because probably, if you hear it end and then start up again, it would just make you aware of how much time had gone by. Which would make you sad. Or mad. We talk about what Ferdie is doing right now. We talk about work. Minutes pass.
朱莉和我谈论了等待时的音乐。朱莉注意到这首歌没有开头也没有结尾。因为很可能，如果你听到它结束然后又重新开始，它只会让你意识到过去多长时间了。这会让你难过。或者愤怒。我们谈论弗迪现在在做什么。我们谈论工作。几分钟过去了。
Oh god. Now what do you want to do?
噢，天哪。现在你想做什么？
I don't know.
我不知道。
And then, after twelve and a half minutes.
然后，在十二分半钟之后。
Yes, ma'am, thank you very much for holding. I have now Miss Christian on the other line.
是的，女士，非常感谢您的等待。我现在让克里斯汀小姐在另一条线上。
Hi Julie.
你好，朱莉。
She's from our priority customer support, and Miss Christian will be assisting you further with regards to your concern for today ma'am. OK?
她是我们的优先客户支持，克里斯汀小姐将就您今天关心的问题为您提供进一步的协助，女士。好吗？
OK, thank you.
好的，谢谢。
Have a good day, it's up to you Miss Christian.
祝您有愉快的一天，克里斯汀小姐，接下来交给您了。
OK, thank you so much.
好的，非常感谢。
Hi. And I should tell you, we told Ferdie this, we're recording this for possible national radio broadcast on public radio--
你好。我应该告诉你，我们已经告诉弗迪了，我们正在为可能在公共广播电台进行的全国性广播节目进行录音——
OK, at this time you don't have our permission to record this, OK?
好的，此时此刻你们没有我们的许可录音，好吗？
Why not?
为什么不呢？
Because I don't know why you're calling, first of all. Second, you don't have our permission to record this, so I just need to ask that you stop recording the call or else I will have to disconnect and call you back.
因为首先我不知道你们为什么打电话。其次，你们没有我们的许可录音，所以我只能要求你们停止录音，否则我将不得不挂断电话并回电。
OK. I will stop recording the call.
好的。我会停止录音。
Julie tells this woman, Christian King, the history of her case. This takes half an hour. Christian is from the corporate PR office, and she tells us that she can get this solved. She says that somebody's going to call us back tonight or tomorrow, that under no circumstances should we call the regular customer service center. That it was just wrong for us to call up and record like that. We got off the phone, and then we turned back on our tape recorder.
朱莉告诉这个女人，克里斯汀·金，她案件的历史。这花了一个半小时。克里斯汀来自企业公关办公室，她告诉我们她能解决这个问题。她说有人会今晚或明天给我们回电，在任何情况下我们都不应该给普通客户服务中心打电话。我们那样打电话并录音是错误的。我们挂断了电话，然后我们重新打开了录音机。
So what do you think?
那你觉得怎么样？
I mean, I think it's such a crappy system. I think it's such a crappy system that now they're all like, you know, we're on the case and we're going to take care of it and stuff. You know, but don't call here, and say that they're on the air, and don't call and say that you're a journalist and doing a story about that, because that just is rude. But that's the only way that I got through to these people. That's the only way that I got this woman to respond to us. It just makes me so angry.
我的意思是，我觉得这是一个如此糟糕的系统。我觉得这是一个如此糟糕的系统，以至于现在他们都好像是，你知道，我们正在处理此事，我们会处理好的。你知道，但别打这里，别说你们在直播，别打电话说你们是记者正在做一个关于此的故事，因为那只是粗鲁。但这确实是我能联系到这些人的唯一途径。这也是我能让这个女人回复我们的唯一途径。这真的让我很生气。
It takes a week and a day, and then a letter arrives by Fedex for Julie, resolving the entire thing. Crediting her account, fixing the mistake. It's done. A few weeks after that, after I do a fair amount of pleading on the phone with MCI, they finally agreed to let us interview somebody in the company. Not Chuck Carter, who I begged for, but instead the senior vice president who runs customer service for MCI. A guy named Jim Myers, who actually started at the bottom handling customer calls himself, and who turns out to be the ideal possible spokesman for MCI. Honestly, sometimes we wondered if they actually just manufactured him in a laboratory somewhere.
过了一周多一天，朱莉收到了一封联邦快递寄来的信，解决了整个问题。贷记了她的账户，修正了错误。搞定了。在那几周后，在我给MCI打了相当多恳求的电话后，他们终于同意让我们采访公司里的某个人。不是我苦苦哀求的查克·卡特，而是负责MCI客户服务的高级副总裁。一个叫吉姆·迈尔斯的家伙，他实际上是从底层处理客户呼叫起家的，结果证明他是MCI理想的发言人。老实说，有时我们怀疑他们是不是真的在某个实验室里制造了他。
Hi, good morning, it's Jim Myers.
你好，早安，我是吉姆·迈尔斯。
Hi Jim Myers.
你好，吉姆·迈尔斯。
Hi Julie, I promise I'm not your enemy. Although after reading the dialogue that has transpired with your account, I'm not-- words can't even describe how you must feel.
你好，朱莉，我保证我不是你的敌人。尽管在阅读了你账户的对话记录后，我不是——言语甚至无法形容你的感受。
Oh, that's so nice of you to say.
噢，你这么说真是太好了。
And I acknowledge and recognize that we owe you an apology.
而且我承认并意识到我们欠你一个道歉。
Oh that's very nice of you to say, thank you.
噢，你这么说真是太好了，谢谢。
That's right. He had us at hello. And then he cheerfully answered all of our questions. Yes, it is true, he said. MCI customer care representatives do not have their own individual phone extensions. Yes, it is true, he said, MCI understands that there have been weaknesses in its customer care, and that's why they've been investing millions of dollars in new training. And why MCI has gone on kind of a hiring binge. The number of customer care operators has increased by a third in just one year. It's now 5,300 people at over 15 locations, under Jim's direction.
就是这样。他一开口就征服了我们。然后他愉快地回答了我们所有的问题。是的，是真的，他说。MCI客户关怀代表没有自己的个人电话分机。是的，是真的，他说，MCI理解其客户关怀存在弱点，这就是为什么他们一直在投资数百万美元用于新的培训。这就是为什么MCI一直在进行招聘热潮。客户关怀运营商的数量在一年内增加了三分之一。现在在吉姆的领导下，在15个以上的地点有5300人。
They've even been testing a system that would solve one of the biggest problems Julie had with MCI. That whenever somebody figured out what was going on with her account, she could never talk to them again.
他们甚至一直在测试一个系统，将解决朱莉在MCI遇到的最大问题之一。即每当有人搞清楚她的账户发生了什么时，她就再也无法与他们交谈。
It will remember who you spoke to the last time, and it will offer that up to you as a customer or consumer calling in. So what would happen is, Julie, the next time you would call customer service it would say, the last time that you called MCI you spoke to Ira Glass. Ira will be available in about five minutes. If you'd like to speak to Ira, press or say one. Or otherwise, press two and you can talk to the next representative in 30 seconds or whatever the hold time is.
它会记住你上次和谁谈过，并且它会向打进来的客户或消费者提供这个信息。所以会发生的是，朱莉，下次你打电话给客户服务时，它会说，上次你打给MCI时你和艾拉·格拉斯谈过。艾拉大约五分钟后有空。如果你想和艾拉说话，请按或说一。否则，请按二，你可以在30秒或其他等待时间内与下一位代表通话。
Now one of the things that we need you to respond to is this. Over the course of her calls Julie talked to a service representative named Melanie Gladwell, who told her that she had to contact the complaints division in Iowa. And she said that they don't have a phone number. That she couldn't call the complaints division to straighten out the problem. They only have a fax machine. Do you have a complaint office in Iowa City that doesn't have any telephones, but only a fax machine?
现在我们需要你回应的一点是这个。在她的电话过程中，朱莉与一位叫梅兰妮·格莱德威尔的服务代表谈过，她告诉她必须联系爱荷华州的投诉部门。她说他们没有电话号码。她不能给投诉部门打电话来理顺这个问题。他们只有一个传真机。你们在爱荷华市有一个投诉办公室，没有电话，只有一个传真机吗？
Well, I wouldn't call it the complaint office. It's the executive escalation office. And they do take phone calls. I'm not sure why that would have been said by Melanie.
嗯，我不会称它为投诉办公室。那是高管升级处理办公室。而且他们确实接听电话。我不确定梅兰妮为什么会那么说。
Oh, they do take phone calls.
噢，他们确实接听电话。
Yeah. We're a phone company. We should be able to get a phone number for you to just about any department.
是的。我们是电话公司。我们应该能为你提供几乎任何部门的电话号码。
That's what I wondered.
我也是这么想的。
Was Melanie new by chance?
梅兰妮是碰巧刚入职吗？
No, Melanie was a supervisor.
不，梅兰妮是一位主管。
Yeah, she was priority customer service.
是的，她是优先客户服务。
OK. I'll definitely look into that, because it doesn't sound exactly the way things should be.
好的。我一定会调查这件事，因为这听起来并不完全像事情该有的样子。
She hated me, though.
她讨厌我，不过。
She did not.
她没有。
She did.
她有。
I can't believe that's possible on anyone here. Now, Julie of all people, my goodness, I can't believe you're even talking with us after this. But we're certainly glad that you are.
我无法相信这对这里的任何人来说是可能的。现在，朱莉，天哪，我无法相信你在经历了这一切后还愿意和我们说话。但我们当然很高兴你愿意。
I really appreciate you talking with us today. And I really appreciate the fact that I did get the credit. But I have to say that one of the frustrations is that I feel like, if we hadn't called as the radio show, I think I would still be fighting this. I don't think it would be resolved. I think the only way it got resolved was simply because we're a national radio show, and we're just sort of threatening embarrassment.
我真的很感激你们今天和我们谈话。而且我真的很感激我确实得到了信用额度。但我必须说，挫折之一是我觉得，如果我们不是以广播节目的名义打的电话，我想我还会为此而战。我不认为这会得到解决。我认为唯一解决它的原因是，仅仅因为我们是一个全国性的广播节目，我们只是在威胁说要让他们难堪。
Wow. That's actually somewhat disappointing. And I will tell you at some point, I hope you come back and do business with us. And I think you'll see that the tone and the spirit and the delivery of our service is significantly better.
哇。那确实有点令人失望。而且我会告诉你，在某个时刻，我希望你回来和我们做生意。而且我想你会看到我们服务的语气、精神和交付方式有了显著的提高。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And Julie, I promise, we will treat you like a princess. Maybe I should go out on our VRU and our response and just put my email. And say, look, if your issue's not resolved to your satisfaction, send me an email. Maybe there's an opportunity to go one step more.
还有朱莉，我保证，我们会像对待公主一样对待你。也许我应该去我们的VRU和我们的回复中，把我的电子邮件放上去。并说，看，如果你的问题没有得到你满意的解决，给我发邮件。也许有机会再多做一步。
I'm sorry, are you saying that you want us to--
抱歉，你是说你想让我们——
Sure--
当然——
--broadcast your email address?
——广播你的电子邮件地址？
Sure, why not?
当然，为什么不呢？
OK.
好的。
All right, what's your email address?
好的，你的电子邮件地址是什么？
[email protected]
[email protected]
All right, all you MCI customers. You heard it. Let's give that one more time, the email address.
好的，所有MCI的客户。你们听到了。让我们再给一遍，电子邮件地址。
It's Jim.myers--
是 Jim.myers ——
M-Y-E-R?
M-Y-E-R-S at mci.com.
M-Y-E-R-S at mci.com。
OK.
好的。
Julie, I have your number. I'm going to do something for you. But I'll take it off line.
朱莉，我有你的号码。我要为你做点什么。但我会在线下做。
Oh.
噢。
No, here we are. Do you want to say?
不，我们在这。你想说吗？
No, no. I'm going to look through this record. And, you know, I can't pay Julie for her time and whatever. You know. I tend to write people letters and do special things. Just let them-- you know, I'm not going to write on the chalk board a thousand times, I'm sorry for what we did, but I'll do something special for you.
不，不。我要看这个记录。你知道，我不能付钱给朱莉补偿她的时间和什么的。你知道。我倾向于给人们写信做些特别的事情。只要让他们——你知道，我不会在黑板上写一千遍“我对我们所做的感到抱歉”，但我会为你做些特别的事情。
Well, I would appreciate anything. Thank you so much.
好吧，我会感激任何事情。非常感谢。
We'll do a little something nice for you.
我们会为你做些好事。
OK.
好的。
OK. All right.
好的。好的。
Thanks so much.
非常感谢。
All right, bye.
好的，再见。
Wow.
哇。
Are we being suckers?
我们是被耍了吗？
Yes. I think, he said he was going to treat me like a princess. I wonder what I'm getting.
是的。我想，他说他要像对待公主一样对待我。我想知道我会得到什么。
Christmas is coming, baby.
圣诞节要到了，宝贝。
An ice cream party? You know what, I would love it, is if the gift he sends me is a CD of the music that they play while you're on hold.
冰淇淋派对？你知道吗，我会很喜欢，如果他送我的礼物是他们在你等待时播放的音乐CD。
Two days after we talked to Jim Myers, Julie received a huge gift basket from him at her house, filled with chocolate treats and fancy cheeses and gourmet crackers. And a very nice note. And with that, she no longer wanted revenge. For 10 months, the worst thing, the most infuriating thing, was that she was trapped in an impossible situation where there was no court of appeal. As an individual you can't even sue the phone company for all your lost time and your mental anguish. And then, she found the thing all of us always yearn for in this situation. She found a higher judge who could fix it.
在我们和吉姆·迈尔斯交谈两天后，朱莉在她家收到了他送的一大份礼物篮，里面装满了巧克力零食、高级奶酪和美味饼干。还有一张非常好的便条。有了这个，她不再想要报复了。10个月里，最糟糕的事，最令人愤怒的事，是她被困在一个不可能的境地，没有任何上诉法院。作为个人，你甚至不能因为所有失去的时间和精神痛苦起诉电话公司。然后，她找到了我们所有人在这类情况下总是渴望的东西。她找到了一个能解决问题的更高级法官。
It's now been four years since Julie had her problems and we talked to Jim Myers. And sadly, Jim Myers is no longer at MCI. In fact, MCI no longer exists. They merged with Verizon last year. If you are in a situation where you are having difficulties with your phone company, here's what you can do. You can go to the Better Business Bureau's website, bbb.org, or the FCC's website. They've got a section for this at fcc.gov. Or, for the most effective solution, the one that as we've shown really works, funding for new radio shows is done by the Corporation for Public Broadcasting two times each year. Application dates every April and November.
距离朱莉遇到问题和我们与吉姆·迈尔斯谈话已经过去四年了。遗憾的是，吉姆·迈尔斯不再在MCI工作了。事实上，MCI不再存在了。他们去年与Verizon合并了。如果你遇到与电话公司有困难的情况，你可以这样做。你可以去商业改进局的网站bbb.org，或联邦通信委员会的网站。他们在fcc.gov有一个专门的章节。或者，对于最有效的方案——正如我们展示的，真正有效的——新广播节目的资金是由公共广播公司每年两次资助的。申请日期在每年的4月和11月。
The program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Jane Feltes, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr and Starlee Kine. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder.
该节目由亚历克斯·布鲁姆伯格和我本人制作，简·费尔特斯、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔和斯塔莉·凯恩参与。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our web site, www.thisamericanlife.org. Or as we like to call it, your holiday shopping wonderland. We have signed posters from our last live show tour. We have signed copies of The New Kings of Nonfiction. And a brand new, live CD of a conversation that I had on stage with three of the kings of nonfiction-- writer Susan Orlean, Chuck Klosterman, and Malcolm Gladwell.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。或者正如我们喜欢称呼的那样，你的假日购物仙境。我们有上次现场表演巡演的签名海报。我们有《非虚构文学的新国王》的签名版。还有一张全新的、现场的CD，关于我在舞台上与三位非虚构文学之王的对话——作家苏珊·奥尔良、查克·克洛斯特曼和马尔科姆·格拉德威尔。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who knows that only one person can stop me from talking about him right here in the credits.
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他知道只有一个人能阻止我在这里的致谢名单里谈论他。
Chuck Carter, just Chuck Carter.
查克·卡特，只是查克·卡特。
That's right. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
没错。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。